all right should we cruise to the Bone
Zone we could what is this edible anus
chocolates
let's eat some of these
on the podcast edible anus you're
kidding is this is the name of the brand
because that's kind of sick the world's
first chocolate anus first saw the light
of day in 2006 London artist Magnus
Irvin made a range of them a
multi-colored chocolate to present in an
exhibition how did he do it I
at that show he definitely took a mold
of his own [__]
initially Mr Irvin tried to cast his own
anus with messy and disastrous results
whilst explaining his failure to a
chance acquaintance at a bus stop he was
gratified to find that his fellow boost
passenger was willing to allow him to
cast her anus
the job the job was done in just over
half an hour later that afternoon and
all subsequent anuses have been based on
this casting it is a matter of interest
that the person who kindly donated his
service has no idea that her anus has
now gone Global was she hot though
that's crazy of a stranger just in your
apartment with her ankles by her head
like on her neck she's like how's that
yeah perfect perfect what was the
conversation
like like how did he even Broach that
with her he's just sitting down at the
bus stop
yeah yeah yeah
oh what's wrong I've just ugh
quite a story I'm
I'm an artist and I I try to create a
mold of my anus but it was
too painful it was quite uh quite messy
yeah
well Ivan anus I suppose we all do don't
we yeah yeah we've been eaten anything
today yeah would you like a would you
like to try
make them old of my anus yeah yes what
bloody hell
okay then we'll get off in a few stops
in my apartment and we'll uh we'll catch
join us
that's pretty
she's sitting there like this she's
casting her anus she's like I thought
this whole thing was a euphemism for
like we're gonna have sex no he's like
no I'm for real I'm making butthole
chocolate I feel like it's pretty
British to be like
yeah holy [__] dude I could eat that out
[Laughter]
I could lick that dude that's pretty
good yeah that's pretty funny yeah I
didn't really get the whole perspective
before what I was gonna say it feels
pretty British to just kind of like
what you do for work
I'm an artist
all right what you working on
you're gonna try to create a mold of my
anus but it didn't quite work oh you
need a model
I do actually
okay I've got 30 minutes
right and then they just go do it yeah
we should bonus this
is just porn this is just porn it's only
. to cast your own
this is a wonderful Valentine's Day gift
or no yo Mother's Day
Dad I've got you something
I actually can't believe like this is
real
I thought they would have just made
chocolates that look like that yeah and
lied about the casting the [__] thing
like it's pretty easy to make that yeah
it looks like you're just cutting down
the middle of an orange
wow all right let's jump to the bonus yo
can we watch this girl mold her ass yeah
just kidding s You're Gonna Love you're
gonna love this Matthew McConaughey
thing yeah you're gonna love our Matthew
McConaughey no you are it's so good he's
standing his stage
behind him he has screens with all the
people that bought like the Zoom pass or
whatever and it's all middle-aged
mothers well dude you saw we fired some
people up man what Lou fired some people
up but what do you mean the Maddie
mcconies really they were in our
comments bro really getting hard like
saying what saying mean [__] dude
actually about us no way like Noelle and
Cody are just so condescending
did they actually say that he's trying
to do something positive man at least
it's free in the comments they were
saying you may not [__] with it
wow holy [__] Maddie get off your burner
man talk to us
people like that are A-list like him
don't have really dedicated
because you can't really get that close
to him you know yeah
so I'm surprised to find that people
like have us back like that
I think you know what I'm saying yeah I
agree I I think but I think he kind of
has that Old Guard Hollywood yeah yeah
where he's like one of nine celebrities
yeah and he's the one that people chose
yeah Matthew is my guy yeah I mean I
guess if he read his book or whatever
and you
you would feel like you'd know about his
life and you know about him as a person
you think look this up
are there Matthew McConaughey posters
we should get one
this wall is still
blank as hell yeah
it's true I'm gonna fill that up
yeah yeah so okay this this photo has
probably been at some person's work desk
for 15 years is that your husband
yeah that's a nice photo is that your
husband
yes I wish no no not I wish yes
it is that is my husband I mean that
one's just [__] hot
[Music]
the other one was more of a joke but
this one's just straight up sexy as hell
well where I was going with this was
you know before the phone
if you were a hot guy you were printed
on paper like they would burn down trees
to be like this guy needs to be in your
[__] office and your bedroom yeah
that's funny he's from that era yeah
to be printed yeah that's a pretty big
deal yeah yeah just some [__] yeah
just some Brazilians in a forest yeah
yeah
what's this for
Matthew McConaughey posters
ah nice
yeah so I think but I think you're right
because if you project current day it is
hard to get close to him but because I
think he's a hot poster guy
I just yeah yeah
he has that I think like the most people
that are like online like you know like
looking for hate about the people that
they like and then being like how dare
you hate these like BTS fans and like
you know Harry Styles fans it's like
modern day celebrities yeah
that cultivate that kind of fan base but
I feel like Matthew's like too old for
that yeah but I guess maybe you're right
it's just the poster crew yeah it's all
people would that had him as a poster
you can tell it's poster crew because
everyone that got like really hot with
us
paragraph yeah yeah okay it's like
that's like you know that's like some
middle-aged Behavior yeah
and to think that yeah I know it's also
like he's so famous that like us making
fun of like it just doesn't even it
doesn't it's a drop in the bucket like
yeah the one this has this one this came
out yesterday dude I'm not close this
I'm not reading it again
I want a dude dude no no we can read it
on the break I'm not gonna listen listen
here Cooter town
[Laughter]
dog us out
okay
what's so funny about the whole
McConaughey thing yes the advertisement
is a bit spammy it's marketing he's
giving a free sort of Master Class to
share some life experience and help
people through hardship not for everyone
sure but isn't that just very kind and
selfless oh the VIP thing for which you
pay is not too much is not too much look
hold on he's got a spell over these
people don't you wish you were this sexy
yes yeah where you're like
come see me for forty dollars
and people are like
so kind and selfless of you yeah for you
to come down from up there it's a
virtual road trip yeah
Matthew you shouldn't you should be
going on road trips by yourself with
your friends not us us you're so kind
our lowly little regular
ugly little selves
wait go back I want to finish it
it include it includes being part of the
zoom call where you can directly ask him
a question but even better you donate
food slash meals to people in need
that's actually cool that is cool I
don't know any more about it than the
next person
okay this is maybe a little upset
hearing the boys call it a scam Matthew
is trying to do something good here and
give back which I think should be
applauded rather than made fun of okay
and you know what I'm gonna say to that
Cooter town
you're talking to Two World Renee world
renowned Engineers okay and you know
what we see when we see a website with a
form that says
come on for the Wrath first name last
name email address I mean you cannot
look at that website and not think that
that's scammy that's what scams look
like dude those this web design you know
what this web design is you know this
web design is what
put in your name for a free gift card
that's what this web design is that's
why we think it's a scam yeah okay
so what we're gonna find out for real
yeah in the bonus
um so join our website yeah we have the
ride a ride through space.com
we gotta make our [__] look more like
this dude yeah dude just a big old
button click here for the space road
trip yeah